Ronald Reagan said that a politician has
to be an actor and in the in the
negative sense of this it's because
they're both
vain uh ridiculous sort of Endeavors
that are selfish and self-centered but
when they're done right I actually think
it's for the opposite reason I think
politics and acting are similar because
both have to be concerned with truth
acting is living truthfully in imaginary
circumstances politics hopefully if
you're a good politician you're
concerned with pursuing some kind of
political truth ultimately a cultural or
even religious truth and you have to
like people
if you don't like people a you're going
to hate acting because all you're doing
is building characters you're analyzing
The Human Condition and if you hate
people you are going to be a terrible
politician because you spend all your
time at spaghetti dinners at the VFW
hall or at the Lions Club or something
you've if you don't like them there are
many other ways to make a buck or to get
your name in the newspaper